it's that time again we have to break
down all of the fashion hits and misses
from the billboard music awards last
night so we have our fashion expert back
with us today
[Music]
frank marino is joining us to talk all
things sparkle glitz and glam the more
we do this together the more we match
and we're obviously on the same page
here
so lots to break down from the
billboard's red carpet yesterday i got
to see a lot of them in person and you
sent over your picks earlier in the day
and i gotta say
i'm agreeing with everything pretty much
the same thing so let's get started
we're going to start with anita okay
let's start with anita tell me this fun
fact that i had no idea well okay so the
design is called fendis okay so it's
fendi and versace mixed together they
collaborated on a couple of items and
her dress was one of them which i
thought was absolutely amazing yesterday
it had that it was like a light pinkish
lavender she looks a little like p diddy
oh yeah they look a lot of like here but
by the way let's just go to him last
night he changed seven times he was the
host and i thought every one of his
outfits were amazing but he always looks
good he always looks fresh and he walked
down the carpet and everyone was chasing
him and i was like he just looks like a
model like he just attracted everyone
around he just he brings it to you you
know he does you can't go wrong and when
you're the host you gotta break it
especially with the outfit changes okay
i think we have doja cat coming up next
here
maybe we have the picture uh let's talk
about does your cat are you looking so
doji yeah i love doji cat i love that it
was it was a little risque but it still
was like formal it was fun uh not for
everybody i love the saturn purse
yes and the sides of the dress had some
detail too that was really nice but
i love the idea of the pasties under the
mesh
so nothing is falling out there anything
yet it's still risky all right this next
one this is my favorite megan fox and
machine gun kelly just stunning best for
the whole night vespa he's indulging
cabana i love that suit if they really
had it for sale i think i'd buy it
myself you could work it i could see you
her dress was amazing bangs i thought
she really pulled off yes she did the
hair looked great hers is a david coma
hi but uh i never heard of him but that
dress is amazing so maybe it'll be
making a talk about him exactly all
right next up my pick i'm adding in here
is becky g i just love her i think she's
so young and cute and fun and sometimes
feathers are a little risky
you're not not for me i'm a drag queen
you like feathers like she's just saying
everything she has glitter or feathers
on it
true
all right and last up i think we have
jack harlow here um i thought for the
guys he kind of showed up in something
fun until i thought it was fun but what
turned me off was i sort of thought he
had like an arrogant attitude to the
reporters yesterday oh yeah he just kind
of gave up the way we get no answers i
was like why are you being so difficult
come on this is your moment everyone's
talking about jack harlow okay let's
move on to the misses i agreed with this
first one that we have here heidi klum
very basic for heidi klum i mean i could
see her shopping in beverly hills in
that but i don't think it's really
something she should wear in an award
show and i didn't love the booth i know
gloves are in right now
you're in las vegas yeah and it was hot
yesterday so to wear those gloves in
those boots not necessarily you're a
supermodel
all right next up on our misses list
mary and j blind there was too many
ideas going on in this outfit you know
the top looks like one idea the bottom
looks like two other ideas and i think
it was not age-appropriate yeah i wasn't
loving it and this was her night she was
getting a special award i know she
didn't know that
yeah
and the hair was a little much for me
okay next up dove cameron
nobody should ever wear this dress
and you know she's so young right and
that's the disappointing part and she
has a great body but that dress is going
to make anybody look 20 pounds heavier
than they actually are and she was
walking by i was so nervous i was like
if that dress moves one inch
exactly and i'm also adding in megan the
stallion as not one of my favorites for
the night i'm like again she's having a
moment and that was they keep trying to
show skin and i don't think that you
always have to show skin to be sexy you
can do it in a different way yeah you
can do it in a good way and it's hard
you know it's hard to talk about fashion
sometimes when you really like the
people exactly like exactly i'm a big
fan of hers but a lot of times good
people make bad choices that's true so
hopefully they'll learn from it and last
up city girls i don't know if you saw
them or not
for a minute i don't get it
i first i'm not glad i thought it was
the supremes
i was like it's diana coming
maybe that's the vibe they were going
for i just think the billboards are fun
in a moment to really show off your
personality and like it just i don't
know it's just like the grammys but i
think this time some of the outfits just
didn't work yeah well we're usually on
the same page so frank thanks for always
hanging out thank you and you're a busy
man you've got a lot going on tell us
really quickly about the you can see me
and my drag brunch we have the one at
the west gate i'm doing another one at
dw bistro on memorial day weekend that's
going to be a great one and then i'm in
legend of the concert every night at 7
30 every day but tuesday we got a great
lineup there too dale celine cher you
name it you name it there's nothing you
don't do so frank marina's delicious
drag brunch is happening may 29th at
11am and 1pm thank you so much for being
here always so much fun with you thanks
for bringing the sparkle now i'll send
it over to sally with a look at your
most accurate weather now forecast